Prof: Good morning
everybody.
We have talked in the course of
this semester many times about
the Hellenization of Roman
architecture,
about the impact that Greek
architecture had on Roman
architecture.
And we've talked in particular
about the two philhellenic
emperors,
Augustus and also Hadrian,
and the kinds of monuments they
commissioned during their reign
that were so clearly based on
those in ancient Athens --
Athens, especially of the
Classical period,
the cradle of civilization,
and where scholars often speak
of as the birth of democracy.
I want to turn full circle,
go full circle here and return
to the whole question of Athens,
by looking at Athens itself,
because Athens also became a
Roman colony.
And you won't be surprised to
hear that it was built up under
primarily two Roman emperors,
namely Augustus and Hadrian,
just as one would expect,
the two major philhellenic
Roman emperors.
I show you a spectacular view
of Athens as it looks today.
And you can see here that the
city of Athens--
and some of its antiquities
extremely well preserved--
is a city that is located --
it's actually a city that's
located in plains ,
surrounded by mountains.
And it also has three major
hills, as I think you can see
from this extraordinary image.
One of those hills,
of course, is the famous
Acropolis.
And I think,
by the way, if one were to
make--
I don't how many of you have
been to Athens,
but if one were to make a list
of the ten places that one
really must see,
at some point during their
lives, and experience,
Athens is certainly one of
them, mainly for the Acropolis,
which you see in the center of
this image here.
That's one of the major hills.
The other two are Mount
Lycabettus, which you see in the
uppermost part;
that's actually the highest
hill of Athens.
And then there's another one
called the Mouseion Hill,
which we're going to actually
talk about today,
because there's an important
monument there --
the Mouseion Hill or the Hill
of the Muses.
It's located off this image,
right where I'm standing here.
And those three hills,
as you can see,
rise up in the city of Athens.
And it's not surprising--and
the rest of it surrounded
essentially by a city that was
constructed primarily after
World War II,
mainly residential houses of
six, five,
six stories,
residences that are mostly
white in color,
as I think you can see here.
But the Acropolis rising up in
the center in an amazing way.
The city of Athens we know was
founded in the Neolithic period;
it was founded in the Neolithic
period.
So it goes way back,
in the same way that Rome does.
And it's not surprising to see
them founding the city of Athens
on one of those hills.
And which hill do they pick?
They pick the hill that's the
flattest, which makes it easiest
to build on, and that is the
rock of the Acropolis itself.
So they put their religious
structures on the Acropolis,
and then over time the city
begins to grow up around the
rock of the Acropolis.
Now this is very interesting
because if you think back to
Rome and its beginnings,
you'll recall that Rome too was
founded on a hill,
because hills can be most
readily fortified.
So Rome was founded,
you'll recall,
essentially on two hills,
on the Palatine Hill,
by Romulus, where he
established residences,
but also on the Capitoline Hill
where they built the Temple of
Jupiter Optimus Maximus
Capitolinus --
so that being the religious
center of the city.
We see the same sort of thing
happening here:
the city growing up on the
Acropolis,
and then we'll see that the
meeting and marketplace is down
below,
in a valley,
below the Acropolis,
in the same way that the Roman
Forum,
or what became the Roman Forum,
was in the valley beneath the
Palatine Hill,
and also the Capitoline Hill in
Rome.
So very similar beginnings for
Greece, as also for Rome.
As you all know,
Athens thrived particularly,
Greece in general thrived
particularly in the fifth
century B.C.,
under Pericles,
and continued to thrive into
the Hellenistic period.
But it was in 86 B.C.
that Sulla, the Roman general
Sulla, sacked Athens,
sacked Athens,
made Athens a Roman colony,
and in fact destroyed the walls
of the city of Athens.
So that obviously a very major
point in the history of Athens.
When scholars talk about
architecture that was put up by
the Romans in Athens,
during Roman times,
they talk about it as being
primarily uninspired and rather
derivative.
And you'll find this in your
textbook.
Ward-Perkins talks about how
derivative Roman architecture in
Greece is, of its earlier
counterparts,
that is, from Classical and
Hellenistic Athens.
And I think he has a point,
and it's something that we
should all think about as a
group,
whether we think that the
buildings that we look at today
are,
for the most part,
derivative from the Classical
and Hellenistic past.
But I think to say only that is
to miss the point in part,
because what we are also going
to see,
as we look at these buildings
today,
is that the extraordinary
marbles that come from this part
of the world,
Greek marbles--and we'll talk
about a number of them today--
the quality of those is so high
that it's hard to imagine any
building made out of these,
not spectacular,
just for the materials alone.
And also because the artists
and the architects,
and the artisans who are
responsible for carving this
marble,
had been carving it for
centuries, and consequently they
were particularly skilled at
carving marble.
And so what they produced has
great beauty,
as I think you'll see today.
So those two,
again a very important point,
I believe, about the quality of
these works of art.
And we're also going to see
works of architecture.
We're also going to see that at
least two of them,
in my opinion,
are really distinctive
structures;
different than anything we've
seen before.
And I think that you'll find
they're quite innovative in
their own way.
And we will look at,
as I said, both of those today.
The city of Athens began to be
excavated by archaeologists in
the 1930s ,
and those excavations,
which were scientific,
very careful scientific
excavations,
those excavations,
combined with information that
we have from a writer of the
Greco-Roman past,
a man by the name of Pausanias,
P-a-u-s-a-n-i-a-s,
Pausanias, who was a Greek of
the second century A.D.,
who traveled around Greece and
described everything that he
saw,
and he created,
in essence, a guidebook to the
great Greek and Roman
antiquities.
The combination of his
descriptions,
from the second century,
firsthand descriptions of the
monuments that stood in the
second century,
along with the scientific
excavations of the 1930s and
since,
allow us to get an excellent
sense of what,
not only what,
as we look at the remains
today,
not only of what was there,
is there now,
and was there once upon a time,
but what these buildings
actually were;
their identities and what their
function was in Athens,
either in Greek or in Roman
times.
And we will use the information
provided by both of those today
to allow us to reconstruct the
city, the Roman city in
particular.
Now the building-- as you can
see from the view of the
Acropolis,
there are a number of Greek
structures on the top of the
Acropolis,
and I'll show them to you later.
These include the great Greek
entryway of the fifth century
B.C., the so-called Propylaia;
the famous Parthenon of course;
the small Temple of Athena Nike;
and also the Erechtheion,
which is the only building
we've really discussed in any
detail in the course of this
semester.
A fifth century B.C.
building--you see it here in an
extraordinary view,
now on the screen--the
Erechtheion,
which we believe was built
sometime between about 421 and
406 B.C.,
And the reason that it's
important is not only because
it's an incredible example of
fifth-century Greek
architecture,
but also because of the
buildings up on the Acropolis it
is the one that seems to have
captured the imagination of
Augustus,
and also Hadrian,
when both of them visited the
city of Athens,
but also of the Romans as a
whole.
And you'll remember the reason
for that is essentially the
Porch of the Maidens,
which you can see so well in
this view --
the Porch of the Maidens that
exerted a very strong impact on
Augustus and Hadrian.
Before I talk a little bit more
about the Porch of the Maidens
though, just something about the
rest of the construction.
You can see as you look at the
columns that they are of the
Ionic order,
a particularly attractive and
elegant version of the Ionic
order,
with the Ionic capitals,
with their very attractive
volutes.
You can also see the materials
that are used here.
What you can't see is what's
used for the foundations.
That material is called poros,
p-o-r-o-s,
poros, used for the foundations
of the Erechtheion and also many
other of the buildings that
we'll look at today.
And then most importantly,
most of the building,
the walls and the columns,
are made out of pentelic
marble,
p-e-n-t-e-l-i-c,
pentelic marble,
which is from Mount Pentelikon
in Greece and is the marble that
is used most often for buildings
in Athens,
both in Greek times and also in
Roman times,
as we shall see today.
And it's characterized by being
gleaming white,
really blindingly white,
as one looks at it in the very
bright Greek sun against the
blue sky.
With regard to the caryatid
porch,
the Porch of the Maidens,
the very famous Porch of the
Maidens,
you'll recall that both
Augustus and Hadrian visited
Athens.
They both saw this monument.
The Erechtheion had fallen into
disrepair by the age of
Augustus,
and Augustus was so admiring of
this porch that he made the
decision to have his own
architects and artisans come to
Athens to repair the porch.
And they not only repaired the
maidens, themselves,
but also replaced one.
One was in such bad shape--I
think it was the one in the back
right--it was in such bad shape
that they restored that one
entirely.
When they were there,
looking at those maidens,
restoring them,
they were so taken by them that
they made plaster casts of
those,
and they brought them back to
Rome.
And you'll recall that they
were used in Rome as the models
for maidens that were put up.
Here's a view,
of course, of those on the
Acropolis, from the front.
They made reduced scale copies
for the Forum of Augustus in
Rome, the second story of the
Forum of Augustus,
as you'll recall.
And then down here you'll be
reminded of the caryatids,
also based on those of the
Erechtheion: in this case to
scale,
same scale as those in Athens,
used to line the Canopus of
Hadrian's Villa at Tivoli.
So both emperors,
again Augustus and Hadrian,
very admiring of these works of
art,
and wanted copies of them for,
in Augustus' case a public
structure in Rome,
in Hadrian's case a private
villa at Tivoli.
And we even believe that
Herodes Atticus,
in the tomb that he made for
Annia Regilla in Rome,
that brick tomb,
the second century A.D.
on the Via Appia,
there were two female figures
that were found near,
excavated near that tomb,
and it has been suggested that
they too may belong to that
tomb.
And while they are variations
rather than copies,
you can see that they too owe
their origins to the caryatids.
So this building,
the Erechtheion,
cast a spell on Augustus and
Hadrian, and was widely imitated
in Rome.
What we're going to see today
is that this building continued
to have a very strong impact
also on the buildings that these
same emperors,
Augustus and Hadrian,
put up in Athens itself.
Before we look at Athens,
I want to take a very short
trip to another city,
the city of Eleusis,
E-l-e-u-s-i-s,
the city of Eleusis in Greece,
because I want to make one more
point about the caryatids and
about the important exchange
that we believe was going on
between Rome and Athens,
already in the late Caesarian
period and into the age of
Augustus.
Augustus is sending his
architects,
but we think they are going
back and forth,
and that there is an important
exchange of building techniques,
as well as architectural ideas,
that is happening between Rome
and Greece in the age of
Augustus.
Eleusis--and you see what it
looks like today--is a hilly
town that is located not too far
from Athens.
And it was particularly popular
in the Greek period because--
or particularly important in
the Geek period--
because it had a sanctuary of
the goddess Demeter,
the goddess Demeter.
And the goddess Demeter,
surrounding her was this very
important mystery religion,
the so-called Eleusinian
Mysteries,
after Eleusis,
Eleusinian Mysteries,
that took place here.
And people came from far and
wide to partake of those
Eleusinian Mysteries,
and so the city was built up in
Classical and Hellenistic Greek
times.
It also remained important in
the time of Caesar and into the
time of Augustus,
and actually into the first and
second centuries A.D.,
and over time decisions were
made to add to the Sanctuary of
Demeter,
by the Roman emperors and
generals,
and also--and using,
of course the service of their
own architects from Rome,
but working in concert with
those in Greece.
And one of the decisions that
they made was to provide the
Sanctuary of Demeter with two
additional gateways:
an inner gateway and an outer
gateway.
The outer gateway,
which is the larger of the two,
was put up in the second
century A.D.
by the Antonine emperors.
But the earlier one,
the inner or smaller gateway,
was put up already in 50 B.C.,
so the late Republican period,
put up in 50 B.C.
And there are some remains of
it, enough that we can come up
with quite good reconstructions
of what it looked like.
And I want to show you those
fairly quickly in passing,
just because they underscore
this important connection that
is going on between Rome and
Greece,
in this period.
We see one side--this gateway
actually has two sides--and we
see one side of it here,
with columns and a quite
traditional pediment above.
The triglyphs and metopes that
you see here have
representations of sheaves of
wheat and what are called
cistae,
c-i-s-t-a-e,
which are baskets,
both of which have to do with
the Eleusinian Mysteries and the
worship of Demeter.
But what's most interesting for
us--
and it may be a little hard for
you to make this out in this
reconstruction--
but what's interesting for us
are the capitals,
because the capitals are
examples of the so-called
zoomorphic capitals that we've
seen before --
capitals in which the upper
parts of the bodies of animals
take the place of the spirals
and grow out of the acanthus
leaves.
And I can show you one
preserved example from Eleusis
over here, on the left-hand side
of the screen,
made out of pentelic marble.
We see it here,
and you can see the acanthus
leaves,
and you can see a part of the
upper part of a bull that is
growing out of--
a bull protome that is growing
out of the acanthus leaves.
That should remind you of
something we saw much earlier in
the semester.
Does anyone remember where this
capital comes from?
I know you all know.
Student:  Forum
Transitorium.
Prof: Not the Forum
Transitorium,
no.
The Forum of Augustus;
the Forum of Augustus had these
capitals, some of these
capitals, that included pegasi
growing out of the acanthus
leaves.
So this suggests to us,
this whole idea of having
animals growing out of acanthus
leaves,
roughly--not exactly at the
same time but roughly in the
same period,
Caesarian period into the
Augustan period--
suggests that ideas were
floating back and forth between
Athens and Rome,
in the time of Caesar and in
the time of Augustus.
Now if we look at the other
side of the gate,
we see something that would
seem to confirm that even more,
and that is on the other side
caryatids replace the columns
with their zoomorphic capitals.
These are not;
as you can clearly see--you see
how they have their hands
up--they are not based exactly
on those of the Erechtheion
porch.
They are variations of that,
but they are caryatids
nonetheless, holding the
capitals on top of their heads.
So we are seeing here,
even as Greece becomes Roman in
the Caesarian period,
and into the age of Augustus,
even as Greece becomes Roman--
well it already does,
as I mentioned to you before
when Sulla sacks it in 86 B.C.;
so in 50 it's already a Roman
colony--
and so we can see these ideas
that are going back and forth,
between Rome and Greece,
during this important period.
And we see the power of the
caryatids, even in Greece
itself, as they are imitated
there as well.
From this point on,
for the rest of the lecture,
I do want to concentrate on
Athens.
And I want to begin again with
the Acropolis.
This is actually a very
interesting Google Earth image
of the Acropolis where you can
see--
as it looks today--but where
you can see superimposed on the
current--
on the present remains,
3D versions of the ancient
buildings.
And we can see the ones that
I've already mentioned.
As you enter,
over here, you see the Greek
Propylaia, of the fifth century
B.C., the entrance gate.
You see the Parthenon,
which is the largest building,
a Doric building,
on top of the Acropolis.
And then to its left you see
the Erechtheion.
And in the back the remains of
a museum;
I mean, not the remains,
a museum, that is in part
underground,
which is why it looks so flat,
that houses the original
caryatids and a lot of other
sculpture.
The ones that you see on the
porch today are copies of those
originals that are in the
museum,
as well as other sculpture that
was found on the Acropolis.
And you can also see here the
Odeion of Herodes Atticus,
which I have mentioned to you,
where the Yanni concert took
place,
on the slope of the Acropolis
here.
And then you can also see a
theater--
you see the theater in this
corner right here--
which is interesting because we
believe it dates to the Neronian
period,
which is interesting because
you'll remember that Nero
competed in the Olympic Games
and that he came to Greece to
compete in the Olympic Games.
So it's not surprising,
even though we don't think of
him as one of the great
philhellenic emperors,
it's not surprising to see that
there was some construction in
Greece during the Neronian
period.
I want to turn to what's
interesting actually about what
the Romans do in the age of
Augustus,
when Augustus goes up here
himself,
sends his architects to repair
the porch,
is a decision is made to build
a little shrine to Augustus and
to Rome: a Temple to Augustus
and Roma.
And they decide to put it in
the back left corner of the
Parthenon.
And you can barely see it
there, but it's a small round
building at the uppermost part
of the Parthenon,
between that and the
museum--and I'm going to show it
to you in detail in a moment--
and they build that from
scratch.
But they also take a pillar
that is located right at the
beginning,
or right in front of the
Propylaia that was put up in
Hellenistic times,
and they transform that into a
Roman monument.
And it's those two,
to those two that I want to
turn first.
This is Google Earth again.
You can see the Parthenon,
the Erechtheion,
in these 3D versions.
Can you see just that little,
that round circle,
right next to the edge of the
Parthenon?
That is the Temple of Augustus
and Roma.
And the fact that it is so
small I think is strikingly
interesting,
because it shows that although
Augustus was willing to have a
building put up to himself,
and to Roma,
on the Greek Acropolis,
and so he wanted to make his
presence known,
he did it in a very modest and
very respectful way,
it seems to me.
He could've built much larger
than he did,
and he opted not to do that,
which tells us something about
Augustus and perhaps his
reverence for things Greek.
We are looking at two views of
what survives of this small
round shrine -- actually quite a
bit.
I mean, it's not standing any
longer,
but you can see parts of
columns and parts of the curved
entablature,
curved architrave,
and some of the other building
elements very clearly here,
including one of the capitals.
Again it was a round structure.
It had nine Ionic columns.
It was made entirely out of
stone, and it had a sloping
stone roof.
And this restored view shows us
exactly what it looked like,
as well as how small it was in
relationship to the Parthenon,
which absolutely dwarfs it in
scale,
as you can see in this restored
view.
Here, the small Temple of
Augustus and Roma.
It was built sometime after 27
B.C., and you see it here:
Ionic capitals and then a
sloping stone roof.
And if I show you the remains
again,
where you can see one of those
Ionic capitals still preserved
here,
and we compare that Ionic
capital to the Ionic capitals of
the Erechtheion in Athens,
on the Acropolis,
we see the close resemblance
between the two.
And the reason for this almost
certainly that because Augustus'
architects were working on the
Erechtheion,
were restoring it,
were repairing it,
they were captivated,
not just by the caryatids,
but also by the rest of the
structure: by the quality of the
marble,
by the attractiveness of the
Ionic columns,
with their spiral volutes at
the top.
And they not surprisingly used
those as the model for the
capitals that they carved for
the small shrine of the Temple
of Augustus and Roma.
But I think it also shows their
reverence for things Greek,
and their desire to establish a
dialogue between the fifth
century B.C.
structure and the Roman
structure built right after
Augustus became emperor.
I wanted to mention one other
material that is used in the
Erechtheion.
We talked about the poros for
the foundations,
the pentelic marble for the
walls and the columns.
But if you look here you'll see
the slight blue cast to the
marble that is used for the
frieze.
That is so-called Eleusinian
marble,
from that part,
from the Eleusis area of
Greece: Eleusinian marble with
this slightly blue cast,
and that is used in the
Erechtheion as well.
I mentioned that the Temple of
Roma and Augustus was put up,
was built from scratch;
there was nothing there before
and it was built anew during the
Augustan period.
But I also noted that there was
another monument that we could
call a Roman intervention to the
Acropolis that was actually
already there,
but was transformed in Roman
times.
And I show it to you now.
Here we are making our way,
with all of these other
tourists, up to the top of the
rock of the Acropolis.
We've climbed up the stairway,
which is not at all--it's not
particularly steep.
We've made our way up.
We're about to enter into the
Greek Propylaia of the fifth
century B.C.
Note the Doric columns,
the triglyphs and metopes,
of fifth-century Greek
architecture.
And we see next to it this
pillar.
It's a very interesting pillar.
It's very prominent.
It's the first thing you see
when you enter the Acropolis.
So whoever built this initially
wanted to be noticed;
that's for sure.
And we know it was a
Hellenistic king;
a Hellenistic king by the name
of Eumenes,
E-u-m-e-n-e-s,
Eumenes II, who was king of the
Hellenistic Greek kingdom of
Pergamon,
P-e-r-g-a-m-u-m,
or -o-n --whether you use the
Greek or the Latin spelling--
Pergamon, and he commissioned
this monument in 178 B.C.
to honor himself.
And you can see that the
purpose of the monument was to
create this pillar upon which a
statue of him would've been
placed.
And I show you the pillar once
again here.
And you can see its shape.
It has a stepped base and it
tapers at the top.
And you have to imagine a
statue of Eumenes II of Pergamon
on the top of this monument,
in the second century B.C.
And it was altered in the first
century B.C.
when Marcus Agrippa,
the close childhood friend,
confidant, right-hand man of
Augustus,
his son-in-law,
in fact, decided to replace the
statue of Eumenes with one of
himself.
So he transforms this Greek
Hellenistic monument into an
Augustan monument:
an Augustan monument that
honors Agrippa.
And Agrippa,
it's not surprising to see
Agrippa honored in the East.
He was involved in eastern
military campaigns.
And we'll also see that he not
only--and I mentioned this
earlier in the semester--he not
only instituted a building
program in Rome;
he was responsible for the
so-called Baths of Agrippa that
bear his name--
not much is preserved so I
didn't show those to you--
and also a Pantheon,
the first Pantheon that I did
mention,
the Pantheon that Agrippa
built, that's referred to in the
inscription that Hadrian placed
on the Pantheon:
"Marcus Agrippa made this
building,"
as you'll recall,
the Pantheon that we know had a
caryatid porch.
So Agrippa in Rome is also
carrying the caryatid imagery
into Rome in his building
program.
But he also instituted a
building program in Athens,
as we shall see.
So it was not surprising to see
him honored along with Augustus
on the Acropolis,
and actually in a way that was
much more noticeable.
To be hit by that statue of
Agrippa as you climbed the
Acropolis and went into the
Propylaia must have been very
striking indeed.
This particular structure is
made of a different kind of
Greek marble called hymettian
marble,
h-y-m-e-t-t-i-a-n,
from Mount Hymettus:
hymettian marble.
You can see a little bit of
pentelic here,
but much of it is hymettian
marble.
So the Romans using--the Greeks
and the Romans using a variety
of marbles, but a variety of
marbles that come from Greece
itself;
we're not talking about
imported marbles from elsewhere
in the ancient world.
I mentioned already that below
the Acropolis was the Greek
Agora, or the meeting or
marketplace.
I show to you here a view from
Google Earth of the Greek Agora,
as it looks from the air today.
You can see it is essentially
an open rectangular space.
It has colonnades on some of
its sides;
one set was re-erected.
This is a structure,
a covered colonnade,
that comes from the Hellenistic
period that was re-erected by
American archaeologists who were
responsible for excavating the
agora.
They re-erected it,
in part, to use as a place to
display works of art and for
offices and so on.
But there was more than one in
Greek times.
And this stoa is the
counterpart to a Roman portico;
a covered colonnade,
but they called them
stoas. So we look at the
stoa here, from the Hellenistic
period.
There's a Classical Greek
temple, the Hephaisteion over
here.
And in the center there is a
building called the--
a music hall,
that was built by Marcus
Agrippa,
the so-called Odeion of
Agrippa, that we know quite a
bit about and that we're going
to look at today.
But again what's particularly
interesting,
I think, is the fact that we
see the Greeks building their
religious structures on the
Acropolis,
and then down below the meeting
and marketplace.
And you can see the impact that
this sort of thinking must have
had on the Romans when they made
their own decisions about
building Roman forums.
But there are distinct
differences--and we've talked
about them already this
semester--between a Greek agora
and a Roman forum.
What Greek agoras do not have
is that central,
that focus of having a single
temple on one end,
dominating the space in front
of it.
And they're more square,
whereas Roman forums,
as we've discussed,
are more rectangular in shape,
with again the temple at the
short end.
Any of you who've been to
Athens know that the Agora is
surrounded by an area of Athens
called Plaka,
P-l-a-k-a, Plaka,
a great place--a fun place to
go.
It has been very gentrified in
recent years and now has these
wonderful pastel colored
restaurants and shops,
with the ubiquitous white
umbrellas,
just as you see them in other
Mediterranean countries like
Italy.
I lived in Athens for two years
in the 1970s,
and Plaka did not look like
that then.
But it was an incredible place
to go then, as it still is now,
if you want to really get into
the Greek spirit and dance on
tables and break plates.
You could definitely do that in
the '70s;
a little less ubiquitous today,
but there are still places that
one can find to sort of play
Zorba the Greek in Plaka.
Here is another view,
a panoramic view,
showing once again the Agora,
the Greek Agora of Athens,
as it would have looked as it
grew up from the Classical
through the Hellenistic period.
But the building in question
for us is the one that is smack
in the middle of the Greek
temple and of the Hellenistic
stoa over here,
and that is this music hall,
or Odeion of Agrippa,
which was put up we believe in
around 15 B.C.
And it's to that structure that
I want to turn now.
And this building,
this odeion,
which Agrippa commissioned
himself,
is very important to us in
large part because it
demonstrates that ideas were not
only flowing from Greece to
Rome,
as we've already both discussed
today and in the past,
but from Italy to Greece.
And this is a prime example of
that.
Because if we look at this
axonometric view of the Odeion
of Agrippa,
as designed for Agrippa,
in 15 B.C.--
and this in Ward-Perkins--if we
look at that,
we will see that the plan of
the Odeion of Agrippa is based
very closely on an odeion that
we've already seen this
semester,
the Odeion of Pompeii.
You see it here from the air,
next to the Theater of Pompeii.
You'll remember that the Odeion
of Pompeii dated to 80 to 70
B.C. It was quite early,
built just after the Romans
made Pompeii into a colony.
And it is that exact plan that
is used here.
So clearly again an important
exchange going on,
of ideas, of architects,
between Greece and Rome,
in the Augustan period,
and in this case using an
Italian plan,
a plan from Italy,
as the basis for a structure in
Greece.
We see that it follows in the
main--it follows all the
features of the Pompeian
structure: the semi-circular
orchestra;
the cavea,
divided into cunei;
a stage front here;
pilasters, tall pilasters,
on some of the walls;
an open stoa on this wall over
here.
You can see two sets of
columns, an inner row and an
outer row.
We know that the spectators
entered the structure through
this porch when they were coming
to a musical recital.
And over here there was another
entranceway that was used by the
musicians and also by visiting
dignitaries.
This was a smaller entranceway
that was made up of a small
temple front,
with a pediment and Doric
columns here.
And we can also see tall
pilasters on the outside of this
structure.
And, of course,
this building,
as all odeia,
was roofed in antiquity,
for the acoustics,
and the one in Pompeii was,
of course, also roofed.
Another view,
a cross-section of the Odeion
of Agrippa--
you can see it here--which
shows you the same sort of
thing: the tall pilasters on the
outside of the structure;
the entranceway through this
stoa for the spectators;
the other entranceway over
here, the smaller entranceway
into that part of the structure,
all very well shown.
And maybe, and this may even be
better, this model of the Odeion
of Agrippa, where we can see
what it looked like from the
outside.
We're looking at the northern
end, which is the end where we
have that small entranceway,
with the--very simple
temple-like in appearance.
We can see a series of columns
engaged into the wall down here;
then the very tall pilasters,
with windows between them.
A quite conventional building,
but one again clearly basing--
this is the most important
point that one can make about
it--
clearly based on an earlier
model in Italy.
The capitals are interesting.
You remember the stoas,
the two open colonnades that I
showed you as one wall--
one side of the building,
the inner one and the outer
one,
the--I'm going to forget which
way--
the outer one,
I believe--no,
the outer one I think is the--
there are two different orders.
One of them is Corinthian,
as you can see here.
I think that's the outer,
but I may have that backwards.
One of them had Corinthian
capitals,
and you see those here,
with the narrow--
the elegant volutes growing out
of--
the elegant spirals growing out
of the acanthus leaves.
And the other is of this type;
a type that we have seen
before, but not frequently,
where we have lotus leaves
growing out of the acanthus
leaves.
And that, of course,
is a kind of capital that we
mentioned is inspired by
capitals in Egypt,
and was used also much later,
in much later times,
at the Forum at Leptis Magna,
the Severan Forum at Leptis
Magna.
So a type of capital that is
characteristic of Egypt,
that turns up here.
So it's another example of the
way in which these architects
and patrons are looking at
models from all over the world--
not only the odeion in Pompeii,
but also structures from
Egypt--
and combining those motifs in a
very--
in a new way,
in a very fertile mix,
as you can see.
With regard to the later
history of the Odeion of
Agrippa,
over the years students
sometimes have asked me--
I haven't heard--gotten this
question this semester yet--
but students have asked me,
or have said to me:
"Professor Kleiner,
you show us,
in the course of this semester,
all of these great works of
Roman engineering and
architecture--
the Pantheon and the Colosseum
and aqueducts and so on and so
forth--
and everything--you do tell us
about fires,
that fires sometimes destroy
these works of art,
or works of architecture are
destroyed because other natural
events,
like events of nature like
earthquakes and so on.
But you never tell us about the
buildings that failed.
Were the Roman architects
always successful,
or did they build buildings
sometimes that fell down?"
And so I always use this as an
example.
Because yes,
they sometimes did make
mistakes and some of their
buildings did collapse.
And this is one of them,
the Odeion of Agrippa.
After it was viewed and
described by Pausanias,
the roof collapsed;
collapsed entirely.
Now it had lasted quite awhile,
from the time of Augustus to
the time--
to the second century of
Pausanias,
but nonetheless the roof
collapsed entirely,
and the roof had to be
completely rebuilt.
And at the same time the
architects decided to modernize
the northern end of the
structure and to add a new
portico to the building.
They also changed its use,
by the way, from an odeion to a
general lecture hall,
during that period.
So in 150 A.D.
we see that the northern end is
completely redone.
And it's interesting to see
what they decided to do.
They replaced that very small,
conservative,
Doric entryway with something
with a lot more pizzazz,
as you can see:
a series of male figures--
these are male tritons,
t-r-i-t-o-n-s,
tritons, which are essentially
male mermaids,
male tritons;
tritons that are essentially
male mermaids--on these tall
decorated bases,
as you can see here.
And their gestures are mirror
images of one another,
or reversed images of one
another, which creates a certain
liveliness to the faade,
to the northern faade,
that this building did not have
before.
And that happened again in the
mid-second century A.D.
And interestingly enough,
much of what survives today are
those tritons.
You can still see them on their
bases here, on their tall bases,
or part of them here.
And you can see the
relationship of the Odeion of
Agrippa, in this very good
image, to the Acropolis in
Athens.
You can see the Erechtheion
peeping up over there.
You can see the great pedestal
that Agrippa would've had his
statue on, right here.
So I'm very tempted to say--in
fact I will say--
that I don't think that was
lost on the designers,
that when they chose this spot
for the Odeion of Agrippa they
had very much in mind that it
would be in one of these
interesting architectural
dialogues with the pedestal that
had the statue of Agrippa at the
entranceway to the Acropolis.
I think that was certainly very
carefully orchestrated,
in the same way you'll remember
Julius Caesar and his architects
orchestrated a relationship
between the Temple of Venus
Genetrix and the Temple of
Jupiter OMC on the Capitoline
Hill in Rome.
Despite the fact that you see,
when you visit the Agora,
the Greek Agora today,
and look at these statues,
despite the fact that they are
all that stands,
there's a lot,
you will see that there're lots
of other remains on the ground,
and with those remains and the
excavations that were done by
the American archaeologists in
the 1930s,
the reconstruction that we
looked at,
from Ward-Perkins,
we believe is a very accurate
reconstruction of what the
Odeion of Agrippa looked like.
I want to look at the Roman
Agora, because the Romans
themselves added an agora to
Athens.
If they were going to have a
Greek Agora, they were going to
have a Roman Agora.
We don't know if there was a
practical need for it,
but I guess Caesar and Augustus
wanted to emblazon their name on
an agora or a marketplace in
Athens.
It was put up again in
Caesarian and--started in the
Caesarian period,
and completed by Augustus.
It is right near the Greek
Agora.
We see a view of it here:
a large open,
rectangular space,
with a colonnade around it;
in this case stoas--we would
call these stoas in the Greek
context--with tabernae or
shops at the uppermost part.
An entranceway,
an elaborate entranceway on the
western end, and another
entranceway on the eastern end.
But as you can see it differs.
It is done in the mode of a
Greek marketplace,
because it is more--well it's
sort of in between a square and
a rectangle here,
but it's not as long as a Roman
forum,
and it does not have a temple
on one short end.
So it follows in the mode of
Greek agoras,
rather than Roman fora.
You can see,
if you look at Google Earth,
one can see the forum today,
the Roman--here's the Stoa of
Attalos, in the Greek Agora.
So you can see its proximity to
this new Roman Agora that was
added.
We're looking at that open
space here, with the colonnades.
We're looking at the western
entranceway, as well as the
eastern entranceway up above,
in this very helpful view.
And this is a view I took from
the Acropolis,
looking down on the Roman Agora
and showing the back of the
western entranceway,
which I'll show you from the
front in a moment.
And there you can see Plaka
actually pre-gentrification.
It gives you a sense of what--I
mean, it was really crumbling,
as you can see,
some of the buildings that are
surrounding it.
But nonetheless it was fun.
So here we go.
This is a view of the gate;
it's called the Gate of Athena
Archegetis, as you can see on
your Monument List,
that is the western gate into
the Roman Agora.
We see it here in two views.
And you can see,
when you look at this building,
you can see what Ward-Perkins
and others mean when they say
that architecture in Athens,
under the Romans,
is derivative and uninspired.
It's this kind of thing that I
believe he's talking about.
Because you can see how
beholden it is to traditional
Classical Greek architecture,
in the way in which we see
these great Doric columns,
looking very similar to those
of the Propylaia or the
Parthenon.
You see them here.
You see the triglyphs and
metopes.
You see a triangular pediment.
We never see,
we never see the Greeks--at
least the Greeks in the Roman
period--breaking their
pediments.
They always have complete
pediments, and in that sense,
of course, a very conservative
approach to architecture during
this period.
We know that this,
the gate, was begun by Caesar,
completed by Augustus.
And there's an inscription that
tells us that.
And we believe--although this
is somewhat speculative--
that there may have been a
statue or portrait of the
grandson of Augustus,
son of Agrippa,
Lucius Caesar,
in the pediment --
Lucius Caesar having died in
the year 2.
Here's a view where we see the
Roman Agora as it looks today:
the open space;
the columns around it.
And you can also see this very
curious building,
that looks very well preserved,
rising up on the eastern end,
a building in the shape of an
octagon.
And here's another view of the
eastern end, showing that
octagonal building more clearly.
This is the so-called
Horologion of Andronikos,
or as it is nicknamed,
the Tower of the Winds;
the Tower of the Winds,
which is easier to remember,
the Tower of the Winds.
It's very controversial in date.
I date it here to the second
half of the first century B.C.,
which is when I do believe that
it dates.
But there are others who think
otherwise, and I'll tell you
about that in a moment.
Here's a view that I took from
the Acropolis,
showing the Tower of the Winds
as it looks from up there,
as well as a closer view of
this amazing structure.
Again, you can see how well
preserved it is.
You can see that it is indeed
eight-sided.
You can see one of the porches.
There are two porches that had
temple fronts with triangular
pediments, columns below,
on those two sides.
There was also a staircase that
surrounded the structure.
What this was we believe is
some kind of a clock tower,
a very inventive clock tower.
And although again I think it
was probably built in the
Caesarian period,
late Republic,
John Camp, who's an expert on
things Athenian,
who wrote a book on the
archaeology of Athens,
who has been excavating the
Greek Agora since the 1970s and
is a true expert of architecture
in this part of the world,
he thinks the date is earlier
than that.
He dates it to 150 to 125 B.C.,
and he brings it into
connection with the Ptolemies of
Egypt,
the Ptolemaic rulers of Egypt,
because of their great interest
in the telling of time and the
fact that they did have
important connections with
Athens during this period.
I think he has a point;
he could be right.
But I would add that
connections with Egypt were very
strong in the late Republic as
well;
I mean, keep in mind the affair
between Julius Caesar and
Cleopatra.
Keep in mind that we know that
statues of Cleopatra and Mark
Antony were put on the
Acropolis.
We know that there was a lot of
interaction.
Cleopatra herself came to
Athens.
So I don't think it's
inconceivable that if one wants
to connect this to things
Egyptian, that one couldn't date
it also to the Caesarian period.
But whatever its date,
it's fascinating in its own
right, again because it's
octagonal.
We've talked about the fact
that we don't have octagons in
Rome until the time of Nero.
But we do see them.
You saw another example,
also in Leptis Magna,
the market there,
of the Augustan period.
It's interesting to see this
form emerging--
possibly under Ptolemaic
influence,
we're not sure--emerging in the
provinces,
before it seems to emerge in
Rome itself,
and this being another example.
Here's a view of the monument
again,
but also compared to an
engraving done by Stuart and
Revett,
S-t-u-a-r-t and R-e-v-e-t-t,
Stuart and Revett who made
drawings of monuments that were
in better shape in Athens,
in the eighteenth century.
And what this tells us,
besides showing us what the
porch looked like--
and you can see it well
here--it also shows us that
there was a weathervane on the
top that would have gone in the
direction of the prevailing
winds.
And the reason that we call
this the Tower of the Winds is
not only because of that
weathervane that once stood
there,
but also because of the
depictions of male
personifications of the winds on
all eight sides of the
structure.
And those are extremely well
preserved, as you can see here:
a frieze of these male winds.
And if you look carefully at
the Stuart and Revett drawing,
you also see that there was a
sundial on all eight sides of
the monument;
so its purpose,
needless to say,
to tell time.
The capitals from those porches
are these lotus leaves growing
out of acanthus leaves.
So another Egyptian touch here,
this looking back to
Egyptian-type capitals,
using them here -- the same
kind of capitals that we know
had turned up much later at the
Severan Forum in Leptis Magna.
A detail of those winds;
and here a better detail of at
least one of them,
to show you what they looked
like close up.
And each one of them has a
different attribute,
which has led scholars
obviously to speculate about
which particular wind,
which of the cardinal points of
the compass,
which wind they were in
actuality;
we won't get into those
arguments here,
but there's been a lot of time
spent by scholars on trying to
sort that out.
What is also interesting is the
interior of the building,
which is also extremely well
preserved.
And you can see here,
all in stone,
the way in which the octagon
becomes a dome.
And it is done extremely well,
and one--
I mean, this goes way beyond
any kind of stone dome that we
see,
either in Etruscan or Roman
architecture in Italy.
And it shows us--once again,
it underscores,
more than anything else I could
show you,
the talent of these particular
architects who had been carving
this Greek stone for centuries;
the way in which they are able
to make this transition from
octagonal shape to regular dome
here is extraordinary.
They did not need concrete to
create a great dome in this
wonderful structure,
the Horologion of Andronikos,
or the Tower of the Winds,
in Athens.
The other great philhellenic
emperor was of course Hadrian.
We know Hadrian came to Athens
on three occasions,
and we know the exact dates of
his visits.
The first visit,
124 to 125, Hadrian was in
Athens.
He came another time in 128,
and he came a third time in 131
to 132.
And all the buildings that I'm
now going to show you date to,
roughly, to the times of those
three visits.
The first one you see in an
engraving here.
This was an aqueduct.
When Hadrian came to Athens for
the first time in 124 to 125,
he said, "We need to
supply water to the people of
Athens."
And so he set his architects at
work to build an aqueduct for
Athens.
They created a reservoir on
Mount Lycabettus,
the highest mountain in Athens;
a reservoir.
And then on the side,
one of the sides of the
mountain,
facing the city,
they had--they built a kind of
a structure,
a kind of a bridge that in part
carried that water into the
city.
It no longer survives--there
are a couple of bases from it;
that's it.
But we do fortunately have
engravings that were made when
it was in better shape,
when part of it still stood,
and we see one of those
engravings here.
And what we can see right off,
Ionic capitals:
Ionic capitals clearly based on
those of the Erechtheion.
So the Erechtheion still a
beacon for architects,
still a monument to be
emulated;
emulated in the time of
Hadrian, as it was under
Augustus.
We see an inscription,
and then we see something quite
extraordinary.
If we look very closely above
the right-hand Ionic capital,
we see the beginning of an
arcuated lintel;
straight lintel,
the beginning of an arcuation.
So what does that tell us?
That tells us clearly--and
here's a Stuart and Revett
drawing of that element,
when it was in better shape
again;
a straight lintel,
an arcuated lintel,
with an inscription mentioning
Hadrian.
That is the same kind of
arcuated lintel that we saw at
Tivoli,
at the Canopus,
that we saw in Ephesus at the
Temple of Hadrian,
in Ephesus, showing that this
particular motif,
this arcuated lintel,
very much associated with
Hadrian,
says this is a Hadrianic
building essentially,
and used not just in Italy but
elsewhere in the Roman world.
So again these exchanges of
ideas and motifs and artists and
architects during the Hadrianic
period, as was the case under
Augustus.
Over here we're looking again
from Google Earth at the Roman
Agora.
Next to it a Library of
Hadrian, a library that bears
Hadrian's name,
that was also put up in Athens,
during the Hadrianic period;
specifically in 132 A.D.,
connected to the last visit
that Hadrian made to Athens.
We can see that it is a
great--a large open rectangular
space,
with the library itself at the
uppermost part,
and then a faade that
has projecting columns,
and I'll show that to you
better in a moment.
Here's a view I took again from
the Acropolis showing that open
rectangular space,
as it looks today.
There's some later buildings
built into it.
And here we're looking at the
back wall of the faade,
which we'll see has projecting
columns on it.
Here's a plan of the Library of
Hadrian of 132 here on the
right-hand side of the screen.
And you should be struck
immediately as you look at this
plan,
with its open rectangular
space, with a pool here in the
center,
with the columns going all the
way around,
with an entranceway in the
front, with projecting columns
on that faade,
with a series of niches that
are alternating,
segmental and rectangular,
with again the library located
in that uppermost part with
other rooms forming a kind of
wing on either side.
This should remind you,
without any question,
of this.
And what is this?
Student:  The Forum of
Peace.
Prof: The Forum Pacis,
the Forum of Peace,
or the Templum Pacis,
of Vespasian,
in Rome.
So once again--and it is a
near-clear duplicate.
Even though this is a library
and this is a temple or a
forum--although we talked about
the fact that we weren't
absolutely sure how this was
used;
it may have been used as a kind
of museum in Rome for the spoils
and other works of art that
Vespasian and the Flavians
wanted to display.
But once again we are
looking--the influence does not
flow only from Greece to Rome,
but from Italy to Greece.
And in this case they are also
using, as a model for the
Library of Hadrian,
an important building type in
Rome.
They're using it,
you know, perhaps in a
different way,
but nonetheless they are using
almost that exact plan for this
second-century building.
And I show you here a model of
the Library of Hadrian in Athens
where we see that it was planted
with greenery.
The library was located in the
back.
There was a fairly conventional
entranceway, looking like a
typical Greek temple.
But then these columns that
project in front of the wall;
the statuary on top,
looking very much like the
Forum Transitorium,
which you'll remember bordered
the Forum Pacis in Rome,
and that probably was also
something that they were looking
at.
And here creating--this is as
far as the Greeks go to creating
one of these undulating walls
with the projecting and receding
elements.
It's still fairly conservative,
but nonetheless they've
injected a little motion here,
using the traditional
vocabulary of architecture.
And here we see a view of the
wall, of that faade;
what survives of it today.
The wall is made out of white
pentelic marble,
and the columns are made of a
slightly--
I don't know if you can see it
from where you sit--
but a slightly greenish tinged
marble,
that comes from a place in
Greece called Karystos,
K-a-r-y-s-t-o-s.
So again this interest in
varied marbles;
varied marbles that come only
from the very rich quarries that
Greece has.
They did not have to go
anywhere else to get high
quality marble and to get marble
of a wide variety of colors.
I want to turn now to a
structure that has one of the
most complicated building
histories of any building I've
shown you in the course of this
semester,
and I'll run through that
relatively quickly.
This is the Temple of Olympian
Zeus,
the so-called Olympieion,
that was put up,
or that was dedicated,
by Hadrian, in the year 131 to
132,
on the occasion of his third
visit to Athens.
But it had again a very long
building history.
It goes back to the Archaic
Greek period,
when it was begun.
It was begun by the so-called
Peisistratids--I've put these
words on your Monument List for
you--the Peisistratids,
who were Athenian tyrants.
They began to build it in the
Archaic period as a Doric
temple.
The construction was stopped,
however, at the end of the
sixth century B.C.,
in 510.
It was resumed in the
Hellenistic period,
in 174 B.C.,
when Antiochos Epiphanes--
and his name is also on the
Monument List--
Antiochos Epiphanes,
a king of Syria,
decided to employ a Roman
architect by the name of
Cossutius--
also on your Monument List--to
finish the building;
a Roman architect.
That's interesting that we see
a Greek Hellenistic ruler hiring
a Roman architect;
speaks to that exchange again
that is going on.
He, Cossutius,
decides to use the Corinthian
order;
the Corinthian order.
And he finishes it up to the
architrave, the building up to
the architrave.
And when Antiochos dies in
164--that's where he's up to;
that's where -- 164 they built
the building up through the
architrave using the Corinthian
order.
Sulla sacks Athens in 86 B.C.
And you'll remember what Sulla
does.
This is that very temple,
with the 55-foot tall columns,
that Sulla eyes and says,
"I want those."
And he brings several of those
back to Rome,
to be used in his renovation of
the Temple of Jupiter OMC;
those very columns.
It was the introduction of
those Corinthian columns and
capitals to Rome that made that
the most popular capital in Rome
and in the Roman Empire,
as we've seen.
Augustus wanted to complete the
structure.
He did not do so,
and it was left to Hadrian to
finish it, and Hadrian finished
it according to Cossutius' plan,
in 131 to 132.
And what Hadrian did was put in
this structure statues of
himself and Zeus--Zeus,
the Greek equivalent to
Jupiter;
statues of Hadrian in one part
of the structure,
to Zeus in the other part of
the structure,
and tons and tons,
lots and lots of statues,
additional statues of Hadrian
outside the temple in the
courtyard.
And you see this temple here,
as finished by Hadrian,
as it would've looked in the
Hadrianic period.
You can see that like a typical
Greek temple,
as opposed to a Roman temple,
it does not have a
faade orientation.
It has two entranceways,
one with a statue of Hadrian,
one with a statue of Zeus,
and that it has columns that
encircle the entire monument--
a peripertal colonnade--as well
as a staircase that goes all the
way around.
So a typical Greek temple;
131 to 132.
It's the same time that we see
the Temple of Venus and Roma
going up in Rome;
what I described as a Greek
import.
Hadrian is responsible for both.
And so we see again this
important interchange between
the two, at this particular
time.
A view of what survives of the
Olympieion, its columns,
its Corinthian columns--you can
see the small people wandering
around;
so this is a very large
structure--that I took from the
Acropolis.
Once again here's a wonderful
Google Earth version of the
Olympieon,
this combination of what it
looks like today,
with sort of this 3D imaging
that makes it look also like it
looked in antiquity.
Here you see some of the
columns of the Olympieon,
the ones that still survive.
They are incredibly large and
incredibly handsome.
And I think,
when you look at the high
quality of the carving,
you are struck,
as I am, at why the Romans
decided the Corinthian order was
the order for them,
when they saw these exact
columns on the Temple of Jupiter
Optimus Maximus Capitolinus in
Rome.
When Hadrian made his visit to
Athens,
the last visit to Athens,
in the 130s,
the city busily--benefactors
busily got together to put up an
arch that would be ready for
Hadrian when he arrived.
And that he could parade
through, and that is the
so-called Arch of Hadrian,
which you see here,
in a view of what it looks like
today,
and in a Stuart and Revett
drawing on the right-hand side
of the screen.
Again, a quite conservative
arch: a very simple,
single arcuation in the center;
pilasters done with Corinthian
order;
columns would have been added
here;
a second story, with a pediment.
No split pediment here.
We see a straight,
conservative pediment here.
And the Stuart and Revett
drawing tells us that in
antiquity there was a marble
slab that was located in the
center of that aedicula,
in the second story.
And we know there were statues,
the inscriptions tell us that
there were statues on both sides
of this.
And the statues are very
interesting,
because on the side that faces
the ancient Greek city there was
a statue of Theseus,
and an inscription that said
This is Athens,
the City of Theseus;
and on the other side,
of course, they put up--
in order to pay obeisance,
to honor Hadrian,
and to try to extract favors
from him undoubtedly,
they put up a statue to Hadrian
on the other side,
and that inscription says
This is the City of Hadrian,
not the City of Theseus.
The last monument that I want
to show you is a monument that
is near and dear to my own
heart,
because in the two years that I
lived in Athens,
in the 1970s,
I was working on a book on this
particular monument.
The monument doesn't date to
the Augustan period and it
doesn't date to the Hadrianic
period, which makes it all the
more interesting.
It dates to the time of Trajan.
And it has nothing to do with
either of those two emperors,
but with a man whose name is
mouthful,
and that is Gaius Julius
Antiochus Epiphanes Philopappos.
You don't have to remember all
of that.
I like to call him Uncle Phil.
You can call him Uncle Phil;
that's the easier way to refer
to Gaius Julius Antiochus
Epiphanes Philopappos.
Nonetheless,
he was a very interesting man,
and we know a lot about his
bio.
We know, for example,
that he was the son of a king
of Commagene,
a Hellenistic kingdom in the
eastern part of the Empire,
in ancient Anatolia,
what is now Turkey.
He was a son of that king of
Commagene, C-o-m-m-a-g-e-n-e,
and his relatives had been
kings for some time.
But he was unfortunate;
although he was slated to
become king himself,
he was unfortunate that
Vespasian, the Roman emperor
Vespasian,
conquered Commagene,
made it a Roman colony,
deposed the kings and became
ruler himself,
in a sense.
And so Philopappos,
because of the Romans,
never became king of Commagene.
He seems to have made the best
of it by making his way to Rome,
using his influence and his
high station,
as a deposed king,
to finagle for himself a
position as suffect consul in
Rome.
What was a suffect consul?
A suffect consul was kind of a
consul in waiting;
by that I mean that if one of
the regular consuls couldn't do
his job, the suffect consul
could be brought in as a
substitute.
So Philopappos could sort of
stand and wait and hope that
someone got sick and he could
come in--
or got, you know,
was in war or involved in a
military campaign,
and then he would be called in
to take his place.
So he hangs around Rome for
awhile, and then he eventually
goes back, goes to Athens.
He moves to Athens,
he's honored with all kinds of
titles in Athens,
and he eventually ends up
being--dying in Athens and being
buried in Athens.
And a tomb gets put up in his
honor between 114 and 116.
And we know the precise date
because of an inscription on the
monument,
the still surviving monument,
that makes reference to some of
Trajan's titles,
titles that Trajan held between
114 and 116,
but does not include titles
that he got after that.
So we know that it was put up
between 114 and 116.
And we're going to see that it
features a frieze depicting
Philopappos at the high point of
his life: his processus
consularis,
his consular procession,
when he was made a consul in
Rome.
I show you a view from the air
where you see once again the
Acropolis,
and the relationship of the
Acropolis to the Mouseion Hill,
the Hill of the Muses.
Now what's most extraordinary
is that there's only one ancient
monument on the Mouseion Hill,
and that is the Monument of
Uncle Phil.
We are standing on the
Acropolis.
I love this picture.
I took this picture myself,
and I'm very proud of it
because it just happens to work,
especially because these two
guys happened to be standing
there taking pictures of the
Odeion of Herodes Atticus here.
But we're standing here,
we're looking back toward the
Mouseion Hill.
And you can see not quite at
the apex but almost near the
apex, the monument,
the sole monument that stands
on this hill,
the Monument of Uncle Phil.
How did he rate to be able to
get this sole monument on one of
the three major hills?
You can see it--it's
marble--you can see it popping
up--pentelic marble--you can see
it popping up almost near the
apex of the hill.
If we look at this site plan,
you will see that it is sited
exactly--
you see it here,
on the top of the Hill of the
Muses--
sited exactly in relationship
to the Acropolis,
lined up with what building?
The Erechtheion;
the Erechtheion,
this building that was so
revered by the Romans.
It's lined up exactly with it,
at midpoint,
between the Propylaia and the
Parthenon, exactly on the
Erechtheion.
And this is the view--here we
are standing right in front of
Uncle Phil's monument,
looking back at the Acropolis.
Even if you don't want to go
see Uncle Phil--which I hope you
will;
if you're in Athens visit him
for me.
I hope that you will,
at the very least you want to
stand there with your back to
Phil's monument and look at the
Acropolis.
You get one of the best views
of the Acropolis from the
Mouseion Hill.
You see it here,
and your view is lined up
exactly with the Erechtheion.
Now why is Uncle Phil buried on
this hill?
This is interesting,
because if you think back to
tomb architecture that we've
looked at in the course of this
semester,
we didn't see people buried on
hills.
The Romans don't bury people on
They bury people on flat
ground, outside the walls of the
city, in their necropolises.
Every tomb we've seen was on
flat, essentially on flat land.
Why is Uncle Phil buried in a
tomb near the apex of a hill?
Well as I was writing this book
I looked back to his own
ancestors,
to people in this part of the
world,
to a group of dynasts in a
place called Nemrud Dagh,
also in Anatolia.
And I show you one of their
well-preserved tombs here,
and you can see that the tomb
is built not quite at the--
not at the apex of the hill,
but on the slope of the hill;
in this case not as close as
Uncle Phil's is to the apex,
but moving on that--moving up
on that slope toward the apex.
And if you look very carefully
at this monument,
you will see among the remains
some seated statues of the
dynasts of Nemrud Dagh,
of this area that Philopappos
also comes from.
This is the Philopappos
Monument on the left-hand side
of the screen,
as it looks today;
made out of pentelic marble,
beautifully carved.
It is a kind of a tower tomb
with a plain base,
a curved second story that has
the scene of Philopappos in a
chariot,
at the time of his consular
procession.
And then some statues in
niches, seated statues,
looking very much like those of
Nemrud Dagh.
Up above we think it's
Philopappos himself,
with a bare chest,
headless, in the center.
A figure in a toga over here,
and certainly another figure
flanking him,
another male seated figure on
the right-hand side of the
screen .
Why do I show you the Arch of
Titus in connection to this?
Because we know that
Philopappos' father and uncle
participated in the Jewish Wars,
on the side of the Flavian
emperors,
in order to gain--even though
they'd been deposed,
they wanted to gain favor with
them.
And when Philopappos went to
Rome, this is the monument that
he would've seen,
this monument that Domitian put
up to those Jewish Wars that his
father and his uncle had
participated in,
on the Velia,
with that representation of
Titus in a chariot.
And I think there's no
question--and I present this in
the book as a theory--
that the processus
consularis of Philopappos
closely based on the triumphal
scene of Titus.
And perhaps it's no
coincidence--we don't have too
many pentelic marble buildings
in Rome--the Arch of Titus is
made out of Greek pentelic
marble.
Is that a coincidence?
I don't think so.
Here's a restored view of the
Monument of Philopappos as it
would have looked in antiquity:
the base,
the consular procession,
the statue of Uncle Phil in the
center,
the inscription to the left,
which is the pilaster that
survives,
with the inscription making
reference to Trajan's titles,
that allow us to date it.
And then probably a missing
attic with an inscription at the
uppermost part.
This view over here shows you
some graffiti that have
fortunately since been erased.
I show you the interior of,
or what survives of,
the back wall that would've
been the burial chamber.
Here's a restored view showing
that burial chamber,
the sarcophagus of Philopappos
where his remains would've been
placed,
a statue of him on a console
that still survives,
and then columns and a straight
lintel that formed what we call
a naiskos,
n-a-i-s-k-o-s,
which served as a kind of
shrine to honor him,
on the inside of the monument.
And if we look at this
cross-section of the tomb,
which are in my book,
we see the sarcophagus,
we see the statue of Phil,
and we see the way in which it
is lined up with the
representations of Philopappos
on the outside,
in his--it's kind of midway
between the scene of him in his
chariot and the scene of him
with the bare chest,
in heroic nudity.
So during his lifetime in the
consular procession,
after death up above.
So honored three times in three
statues on this monument.
Here's a view of some of the
figures that accompany him.
They're wearing Roman togas,
because the scene is taking
place in Rome;
that's where the consular
procession is.
They're carrying fasces
like the bodyguards do for an
emperor;
and that too shows the
relationship of this to the Arch
of Titus.
Here we see the scene of the
Arch of Titus,
triumph, and the scene of
Philopappos' triumph;
clearly the one on the right,
in my mind, based on the one on
the left.
If you look at details of the
chariot, you see a naiskos,
again decorating the chariot,
a naiskos that has a figure of
none other than Hercules.
We can see him wearing--holding
a club.
So once again,
just like Caracalla,
we see, in this case earlier,
Philopappos associating himself
with Hercules.
If we look at a detail of his
head, which is unfortunately not
that well preserved,
we see that he is bearded,
we see he wears a rayed crown.
So although he is represented
in this consular procession,
his kingly, what he--that he
might have been a king,
is referred to.
But also his triumph over death.
And if we look at sculpture
from Nemrud Dagh,
we see once again this
interesting relief--
so there's more than one of
these--of dynasts of Nemrud Dagh
shaking hands with Hercules with
his club and wearing a rayed
crown.
So this is another one of these
wonderful examples of this
fertile mix that one gets so
often in provincial Roman art,
where you see a monument
clearly based in part on Roman
precedents,
but also based on the bio of
this particular man and more on
local precedent.
A scene of Philopappos in the
uppermost area,
showing him in heroic nudity.
And the last image that I want
to show you is just to make the
point that interestingly enough
this monument was put up by
Philopappos' sister,
a woman by the name of
Balbilla, B-a-l-b-i-l-l-a.
And Balbilla--I wanted to make
this point because we have seen
so few examples;
it's not that there were none
but they were small in
comparison to those of men,
that there are--fewer women
seem to have put up monuments
than men.
But the examples that we have
are very interesting indeed.
And in this case we know that
the tomb was put up by Balbilla,
a woman who became very
friendly with Sabina,
wife of Hadrian.
In fact, the three of them
traveled together to Egypt,
to Thebes, to see the Colossi
of Memnon, which I show you up
there.
And Balbilla leaves an
inscription when she goes that
she was there;
so she tells us that.
So a very--just to close
today--a very interesting
example of an extraordinary tomb
in Athens, but one that was
built by a woman.
And I think that's a great way
to end on this beautiful
Thursday.
Thank you all.